[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
8 46
das ist die chiffre geworden der black
live matter bewegung den acht minuten 46
sekunden hat es gedauert bis der
schwarze george floyd unter dem knie
eines weißen polizisten gestorben ist
mit den bildern seines todes ging auch
der protest um die welt und löste eine
breite rassismus debatte aus auch hier
in der schweiz
wir fragen uns heute welchen einfluss
diese diskussionen um rassismus
diskriminierung und ausschluss auf den
kulturbetrieb haben herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ich bin hier an der gessnerallee in
zürich und damit an einem theater das in
die offensive geht in sachen zugang und
teilhabe am kulturellen leben damit ist
die gessnerallee nicht allein
aber es ist definitiv noch luft nach
oben in der hiesigen theaterlandschaft
gerade bei der präsenz von people of
colour kaum jemand ahnte wie groß die
solidarität mit der plakette bewegung in
der schweiz sein würde
auf symbolische gesten wie das posten
eines schwarzen quadrat in den sozialen
medien gehörte dazu selbst bei großen
kulturinstitutionen
ein loses netzwerk von schwarzen
künstlerinnen und künstlern hat deshalb
einen offenen brief an die kulturhäuser
verschickt mit fragen zu rassismus und
ausgrenzung
wie viele schwarz die künstlerinnen sind
die ehrengalerie stammler und residence
programm und stipendien vertrackter wie
stellen sie sicher dass schwarz sie
angestellt die künstlerinnen und kultur
schaffen die den ruhm hans zum
diskriminierung ort sprache es war die
aufforderung diskriminierung von people
of colour im kulturbetrieb anzusprechen
das problem also ein symbolischer akt
wir setzen jetzt doch die meisten
kulturhäuser blieben stumm
[Musik]
was ich mich gewünscht hätte ist dass
die institutionen alle das wahrgenommen
hat menschen zu sagen okay wir haben
diesen brief angeles angekommen bei uns
danken wir schauen dass ein mensch den
stars und das ist von mehr austreten
nicht angekommen
brandy butler ist sängerin und
schauspielerin und momentan eine der
wenigen schwarzen künstlerinnen in einem
ensemble
[Musik]
wieso ist sie eher die ausnahme an den
deutschsprachigen bühnen und
kunsthäusern wahllokal von stadt und
kanton zieht dann bist du verantwortlich
zu die menschen die vor krieg wo ihm dem
stadtkanton land lebt und für mich gibt
es keine verantwortlichkeit
wohnsituation in new york kunsthaus kein
ausstellung macht mit keinen schwarzen
menschen in den letzten zwei jahren nur
ein beispiel wer sagt er sagt dann das
nicht okay ist uns aus mir
wiedereröffnung des stadttheaters basel
diese woche in der neuen saison spielen
zum größten teilweise schauspieler
stücke aus dem klassischen
literaturkanon bräuchte es da nicht
etwas mehr vielfalt
gerade wenn sie sagen unsere stoffe sind
zur plastik aber die sind natürlich auch
deshalb klassisch weil sie in den westen
university also weil sie im universellen
anspruch haben die zauberflöte wird
nicht nur in mitteleuropa aufgeführt
also insofern ist das auch muss man auch
da sein eigenes bild hinterfragen von
dem was ist eigentlich kultur und wem
gehört eigentlich welche kultur die
kultur gehört deshalb die frage muss das
öffentlich finanzierte theater nicht
stärker die gesamte diversität der
gesellschaft abbilden wir haben zum
beispiel uns sehr bewusst dagegen
entschieden das jetzt irgendwie groß zu
benennen irgendwie durch zu zählen wie
viele schauspieler wirklich ein
migrationshintergrund haben kann ich das
problematisch wenn das sind da auch
immer sofort zu identität zuschreibungen
die auch eine kehrseite haben
nichtsdestotrotz ich will das überhaupt
nicht diese verantwortung damit nicht
abschieben dass man nicht sehr wohl sich
extrem genau überlegen muss wie
repräsentativ ist dieses ensemble oder
diese kompanie die wir da zusammen
gestellt haben für die welt über die wir
sprechen wollen doch es geht mehr als
ums personal
es geht ums theater das die gesellschaft
reflektiert um relevant zu bleiben
das meint auch ines matthäus sie berät
institutionen die sich verändern wollen
kulturinstitutionen die war es weiter
wieso ein schnell zukunftsfähig sind sie
ganz einfach mehr eine gesellschaft die
40 prozent von der menschen in dem land
hat mehrfach zur türkei die hand wenn
man die geschichte nicht verfällt
verliert man das publikum oder günstiger
das heißt das publikum künftigen den weg
und wenn man die neue geschichte vor der
neue schweizer grenze nicht verzählt
denn er gibt einen täglichen ästhetik
gekommen wie baut man alte und
ausschließende strukturen ab damit sich
vermehrt eine diverse schweiz an der
kultur beteiligen kann personal programm
publikum und partnerschaften und lukas
müller die homogen oder hetero kennt das
überhaupt aufgestellt ist meistens ist
die ganze analyse schon eigentlich ein
ganz wichtiger teil von dem prozess will
das überhaupt sollten mit einer brille
foto universität auf die zersetzung im
programm in personal im publikum warum
das zeigt wo strom
doch immer wieder schaffen
neuestes vorzeigebeispiel ist das
theaterhaus gessnerallee in zürich
größte bühne für freie performance in
der schweiz
sie will zugang schaffen für menschen
verschiedener hautfarbe und mit
migrationshintergrund die sonst kaum je
im theater zu sehen sind
wenn man auch sieht willi personen im
initiator jetzt aufgestellt sind und
sich selber so 0 reflektiert sie dem
team oder nicht wo man denkt ach ja so
könnte ich jetzt auch schaffen dann noch
sind das spieler oder hörten und es ist
es wichtig dass man das explizit
ausspricht aber das ist die schweiz aber
zumindest die dann sichtbar macht und in
ihre ställe ausgiebig zeit nicht schaffe
das andere
das neue programm ist diverse roboter
streetdance geschichten von menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen
der schweiz hier kannst du dich sicher
für ihn hier passiert so was stimmt
nicht und moderatorinnen wie fatima moni
die gerne kritische töne anschlägt wenn
es um den umgang der schweiz mit der
migration geht das theater bekommen
sozusagen das geld vom staat
und das sind die steuerzahler das sind
irgendwie ist die ganze arbeitende
bevölkerung in diesem land und das
irgendwie so dass hier auch zu
reflektieren in dem programm finde ich
es schon also kann man schon sagen man
kann da wird es dann nicht nur für das
erlebten publikum was machen weil das
ist ja quatsch schiffe spiegel ich für
die gesellschaft durch geschichte zelle
und wanderstöcke eine gesellschaft wie
tweets oder zucker studios 4% teil vom
staat also so viele ausländer wie noch
nie in europa nur wie so manche ford
kommt von menschen dann ist für mich
traurig ist traurig und es ist auch
nicht repräsentativ vorgeladen
[Musik]
was die schweiz längst ist sollte auch
schnell die kultur werden diverse mit
menschen aller herkunft und aller
hautfarben
[Musik]
julian börner ist kulturwissenschaftler
performer und kurator und er hat
zusammen mit elisa liebsten sammelband
allianzen kritische praxis an weißen
institutionen herausgegeben es erschien
vor zwei jahren zu den worten schön dass
sie zu unter die gäste alle gekommen
sind heute wie fokussieren ja auf einen
besonderen aspekt people of colour in
der kultur
was hat sich denn jetzt gerade dieses
jahr auch mit black gleisbett verändert
ich würde sagen gesehen dass das thema
nochmal gesamtgesellschaftlich auf den
tisch gekommen ist ja und wir sehen halt
auch eine breite diskussion und
anerkennung von so etwas wie
strukturellen rassismus also dass es
nicht nur ein thema für eine minderheit
ist sondern dass bestimmte menschen auf
ein gesamtgesellschaftliches problem
hinweisen und gehör finden
aber dann kommen wir gleich zum
untertitel ihres buches allianzen
nämlich kritische praxis an weißen
institutionen was ist denn hier die
definition einer weißen institution wie
definieren weiße institutionen in dem
fast alle nicht nur als als eine
hautfarbe sondern dass das angebot in
dem buch als ein komplex aus praktiken
und annahmen und mentalen landschaften
also vorstellung davon also was kunst
ist und was dann eher ein ritual ist zb
einige sachen sind nur eine weiße person
kann so eine hauptrolle spielen kann
irgendwie das gretchen bei faust spielen
oder so er nur die annahme wie sieht
mein zu schließen sich mein publikum aus
das sind vielleicht auch nur weil leute
ja oder die annahme was sind stücke die
wir unserem publikum zumuten können na
ja das ist dann halt so ein deutscher
kanon und dann ab und dann holen wir uns
was aus dem ausland ab und dann wird er
auch dann thematisiert rassismus
ausgrenzung auf der bühne könnte man
sagen reicht doch es geht nicht nur
darum rassismus auf der bühne zu
verhandeln sondern es geht darum als zu
überlegen wer hat überhaupt zugang also
für wen produziere ich diese kulturellen
güter ja also produziere ich die für
irgendwie ein weißes publikum oder
produziert
die für ein publikum das selber
rassismus erfahrung erlebt hat also ich
würde sagen die kunst und
kulturinstitutionen in die hohe summen
an subventionen rein fließen
die müssen halt auf diese post
migrantische gesellschaft die müssen
dort neu verankert werden jetzt müssen
in einer institution ja erst mal alle
anerkennen dass es diskriminierte und
privilegierte gibt wie erreicht man das
wenn wir uns in dieser rassismus
diskussion auf die strukturellen
hindernisse fokussieren und wirklich
schauen warum kommen leute aus gewissen
sozialen herkunft aus gewissen milieus
nicht an die schauspielschulen warum
kommen die dann nicht an die theater er
warum wird sowas niedergeschrieben von
la presse ja dann sind wir denn dann
sind wir bei strukturellen fragen und
weniger bei also ich möchte nicht
darüber sprechen wollen ob der intendant
oder die intendantin oder die
journalistin der rassisten ist ja wenn
ich von der polizei kontrolliert werde
und sage so ich glaube sie haben einen
rassismus problem und der polizist aus
zig weil er denkt ich meine ihn
persönlich aber mich interessiert nicht
ob er türkische freunde hat oder nicht
sondern mir geht um die praxis also und
wie können wir die praxis und die
struktur und die annahmen die dem
zugrunde legen in den fokus
häuser wie hier die gessnerallee die
setzen ja auch veränderungen im programm
und in der struktur was geht es da zum
beispiel mit dem blick auf publica zu
beachten wenn ich die annahme habe dass
eine stadtgesellschaft nicht homogen ist
sondern sich partie polarisiert hat es
bei verschiedenen communitys besteht
dann kann ich anerkennen dass
verschiedene communitys auch
verschiedene kunst begriffe haben
und das heißt ich muss ein bisschen in
die stadt hinein horchen und mit dem
publikum mit den verschiedenen publica
zusammen einen weg finden wie man dieses
kunstverständnis hier na ja so
implementieren kann und ich bin total
gespannt was jetzt hier an der
gessnerallee passieren wird weil ich
glaube dass das neue leitungsteam eine
große lücke
statt zu versuchen diesen kunstbegriff
zu erweitern und zu schauen so was wird
eigentlich sozusagen in verschiedenen
subkulturen in verschiedenen
migrantischen communities gemacht was
ist eigentlich der wunsch dass das
begehren das ist auch der bedarf und wie
kann die gessnerallee da einfach auch
als eine art ermögliche auftreten und
nicht nur als eine institution die sagt
so und jetzt lassen wir das ein und
jetzt das und jetzt das zu den besten
dank
dank ihm
[Musik]
während hier am theater gessnerallee der
zugang für alle im zentrum steht widmen
wir uns jetzt ein begriff der die
abgrenzung betont es geht um exotik als
um das freibad gilt das ungewohnte eine
ausstellung loser thematisiert derzeit
den schweizer blick nach außen zur zeit
der aufklärung eine vorstellungswelt die
bis heute nachwirkt was für ein fremder
wird
all dieses seltsam pflanzen und bäume
und diese dunklen menschen die darauf an
hannah losgehen
was ist das für eine sprache die sie
sprechen das könnte sich der urheber
dieses bildes der schweizer söldner und
maler france war die moulin gedacht
haben als er es vor 200 jahren auf den
französischen antillen malte in bala
doronin in lausanne ist es in der
ausstellung exotik zu sehen
zusammen mit anderen bildern und
objekten aus dem achtzehnten jahrhundert
die meisten wurden damals von reisenden
in die schweiz gebracht und prägten das
riesige bild von fremden die
kunsthistorikerin john dalli hat die
ausstellung mit kuratiert zusammen mit
ihren kolleginnen der universität bern
durchforstete sie schweizer
museumsdepots nach exotischen objekten
aus dieser zeit für uns ist es aber die
herausforderung sie all die geschichte
von 1890 und kritisch hinterfrage es ist
der achtzehnte jahrhundert die große ära
von der mannschaft aber sie war die
große zeit vom transatlantischen
sklavenhandel beschließt das ist ja die
zeit wo mir obd bild schmidt übernommen
und zum teil auch über die stereotype
klischees roma ried hat und natürlich
gerade aktuelle zieht nun hinterfragt
werden sollte heute empfinden wir solche
gegenstände als befremdlich vor 200
jahren waren sie ein statussymbol der
weißenburger sie auch in der schweiz
die polonaise ab 1805 lange zeit im
besitz der berner familie von
graffenried oder dieser verzierte
nautilus pokal der 1730 seinen weg in
die genfer volksbibliothek fand das
exotisches faszinosum es oder
sehnsuchtsort dafür viele sondern
anzeige wie das exotische leben als
warten also mit absicht einen profit
machen wie die ganze ganze warenverkehr
ich natürlich bundes koloniales system
mit exotischer konnte man geld verdienen
warum also solche gegenstände nicht
gleich selbst in der schweiz produzieren
diese figurengruppe aus porzellan wurde
1775 von einer zürcher porzellan
manufaktur hergestellt so stück sind aus
tafelaufsatz benutzt wurde
also auf dem tisch hat man die
aufgestellt und hat das auch aus
konversationsstück erklärt trainer
diskutieren über themen und mit dem
stück im speziellen muss man sie auch
die folgerichtig steht diskussion kommen
und so stück war mir auch wird wieder
zum nachdenken anregen über
darstellungen vom fremden wie hat diese
zeit unseren blick auf das fremde
geprägt und wo verläuft heute die grenze
zwischen faszination und stigma
die gängige definition vom exotischen
wird in der ausstellung bewusst in frage
gestellt exotische perse gibt's geordnet
exotische ist immer das konstrukt
sichergestellt durchblick frankfurt
perspektive es wird daher stellt die
objekte bilder durch zwischen riediger
durch ausgrenzung und es ist ein blick
vom rufs andere hat wirklich gar die
eigene identität natürlich versteckt ein
gelungener knüpfte ausstellung sie zeigt
auch den damaligen blick von außen auf
die schweiz schön zu sehen am beispiel
der darstellung des unspunnen fest der
pariser malerin elisabeth wie seele bra
der französische blick auf die schweiz
als paradies es ist die sehnsucht der
großstädter nach unangetastete natur
oder die chinesischen hinterglasmalerei
mit schweizer trachtenmädchen business
made in china
es ist wichtig sie nur den blick nach
außen zeigen sondern horst und
perspektiven zeigen die schweizer selber
wort knoten sind und zwar schweizer
bevölkerung frauen nicht nur von unseren
reisen die rheinländer auf dem roten
teppich sondern auch der schweizer
städte wo das bild vom kino-erfolg
prägten
der alpenraum war nicht nur für die
fremden exotisch sondern auch für die
schweizer städte gut zu sehen auf dieser
holzschnitt tapete von 1818 die in
großer zahl angefertigt wurde
solche darstellungen aus dieser zeit
begründen den klischeehaften und
romantisierten blick auf die schweiz der
sich bis heute hartnäckig hält und jahr
für jahr tausende touristen anlockt die
ausstellung exotik ermöglicht eine neue
perspektive auf die schweizer geschichte
und sie regt an seinen eigenen blick auf
das fremde zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
hinter den theaterkulissen versatzstücke
große und kleine geschichten
fragmentarisch erzählt auch
schriftstellerin dorothee elmiger in
ihrem neuen buch aus der zuckerfabrik es
geht um einen ganz bestimmten hunger um
begehren gier und kolonialgeschichte mit
diesem wahrlich außergewöhnlichen buch
ist elmiger nun gleich für zwei
renommierte preise im rennen für den
schweizer und den deutschen buchpreis
da kommt sie angefahren
dorothee elmiger mit grad mal 35 jahren
steht sie mit ihrem neuesten buch ganz
oben in der gunst der literatur tätig
was ist das für ein wurf den sie da
gelandet hat recherche bericht ist
protokoll von der recherche um eine
szene kreist unsere dokumentarfilm wo
sich im text immer wieder darauf kommt
aus der zuckerfabrik ist eigenwillig
kein roman aber auch kein renner ist
ausgangslage für das buch ist ein
dokumentarfilm den elmiger im schweizer
fernsehen gesehen hat
es geht um den ersten schweizer lotto
millionär werner bruni und dessen
niedergang eine geschichte die elmiger
gehört über diese mehrere aus finden
will
[Musik]
ein arbeiter war nicht der stelle wo
plötzlich gewinnt eine geschichte wo man
ja immer wieder gehört aber gewinnt viel
geld wird offen katapultiert und
verliert dann aber auch schnell alles
wieder im griff aber sehr schweizerische
kriegt ihn spielt eine schlüsselszene
verändern ist die zwangsversteigerung
des bankrotten lottomillionär unter den
hammer kommen auch exotische skulpturen
die bruni von seinen haiti reisen
mitgebracht hatte
zitate aus der zuckerfabrik am 2
januar 1984 fünf jahre nach seinem lotto
gewinn steigt werner bruni in basel
mulhouse in ein flugzeug und fliegt über
den atlantik nach porto brass
und wenn kunden plötzlich die karibik
irgendwie die geschichte ihnen komplett
sich der insel ist spiel wo wichtige
geschichte wo die versklavten männer und
frauen wurde der plantage geschafft
haben auf der insel sich befreiten
revolution gemacht hat
elmiger folgt beim schreiben den spuren
des lotto millionär sie die karibik und
gelangt von dazur kolonialgeschichte die
wiederum führt sie zur dortigen
zuckerproduktion den zucker mal ganz
viel ableser historisch also eigentlich
wir aufbauen wollen
der ruhm und tabak kann man die ganze
zeit vor der europäischen expansion die
sklaverei oder im zug nur verfolgen und
wie er die er immer mit der schweiz
plötzlich in verbindet
zitate aus der zuckerfabrik in der mappe
der zucker notizen die ich heute heraus
suche auf einem karierten a4 papier das
zwischen anderen blättern mit
stichworten zu zuckerrüben saccharose
und den karibischen plantagen liegt
meine handschriftliche bemerkung
lottokönig war sehr dünn
lottoglück zucker und kolonialismus für
die autorin hängt das alles zusammen und
wirft interessante fragen auf der wert
dieses begehren eigentlich form der herr
hund wird es überliefert
und da war für folge hätte also ist es
immer auch politisch war mir begehrt wo
sie es an abtrieb weißen hunger ist wenn
ich dieses begehren zerstörerisch war
als mitmachst uhr ein mega schreibt um
über dinge nachzudenken
und weil sie das zur kolonialgeschichte
führte war es ihr wichtig sich selbst
als autorin einzubringen
hamburg hält sich mir regen wir in frage
stellt man ihm der text stärken
schrieben europäerin die schweizerin das
buch entwickelt einen sog und man
begleitet die autorin gerne bei ihren
gedankensprüngen ob das reicht für die
hoch dotierten preise wir drücken die
daumen
[Musik]
kommenden sonntag kurz nach elf ist
dorothee elmiger übrigens zu gast in der
sendung 52 beste bücher bei radio sf2
kultur ja hier an der gessnerallee wird
es langsam dunkel das heißt wir
verabschieden uns für heute während
drinnen natürlich noch weiter performt
wird nächste woche da widmen wir uns dem
tatort und seinem kult faktor und wir
treffen die neuen schweizer ermittlerin
in diesem sinne
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
des wissens
[Applaus]